where you get ahead a little indiscreet
so when we're done our reaction you can
pull this one back a little bit in case
a gal over here
Ashley ender one of my good good close
buddies for forever you can follow her
on instagram check out her YouTube
channel link in the description box for
that bad boy have you seen the trilogy
the greatest trilogy of all time I am
NOT talking about Star Wars I am NOT
talking about Lord of the Rings I am
talking about Fifty Shades yes oh you
dog oh you you horn dog have you ever
seen honest trailers no why were they or
they do like a spoiler spoof parody of
it in trailer format from screen jockeys
no just like a pretend trailer yeah it's
like a fake trailer where they were like
breaking down the movie in trailer
format oh cool no oh I can't wait to
introduce you to this
I'm so excited
retail it started with a bang started to
run ROI relationship now in the final
chapter two people definitely rushed
into marriage of their own as these
stuck-up billionaires let's go down
there I'm sick of sharing your thorough
frown with a squad of armed goons
you'll be in charge of your personal
security and a secret room bullet
restraints and torture devices run a
Shannon Corporation whose business is
never really explained thank you ten
bucks is a demoon laser that runs on
blood diamonds crackle identity of
siblings is it to the point now with you
and Dakota Johnson words like this is
gonna start bad but it's almost like
brother sister as his Christian Grey
scapular unquantified you know I had a
dream last night
secured Ed Weiler Anastasia Steele
Watson squeaks like a sex doll cursed
with life
[Laughter]
[Music]
same as you remember it guy
psychologically betters girl defying me
girl what's up token defiance let me
drive it let me drive and guide ploughs
through it it makes it for a beat just
buy your way out of everything Christian
some things don't have a price like
friendship never mind
Webster's dictionary defines sexual
intercourse as intercourse involving
penetration of the vagina by the penis
and by that definition this is a very
sexy movie clearly separate your 7th
grade geometry teacher from a paycheck
and asked for AIDS is a story about
empowering women and sexual freedom even
though the heroine marries the first guy
she has sex with gets her dream job
because he bought the company spends
most of her free time hogtied and after
spending a movie fighting against being
barefoot and pregnant ends the trilogy
literally barefoot and plays King
dungeon I know it was for me try this
flashback of the dumbest moments the
franchise laters baby can't wait to
never see you again
alright on your
hi Joe you've been fired strike it
you are this no you're not pretty nose
in my butt word I was being romantic and
then you just go and distract me with
your kinky
9:50 [ __ ] Oh Jess go and watch Safari no
fifty shades freakin put me with the
Princeton scholarship graduate single I
pay for publishers in New York in
Chicago before I sent a betting up job
team
you found his LinkedIn why is gomorrah
volumes Steve Rogers yeah she hasn't
seen a fan anymore good word
bring me the nose lost in a war I don't
feel so good
you can you forget about the last one
so why'd you think of honest trailers
there Emmy nominated yeah they're great
have so many you can binge-watch the
hell out of these on your own why are
there so many I know what I'm doing on a
Friday
I've seen all three okay so he's like he
makes very very good points about a lot
of these things and a lot of these
things I was actually thinking while
watching the movie especially when he's
like they got married too fast or
Russian do it too fast they're sitting
there eating dinner and she's like so do
you ever think about having the names
and all these things the second one is
the only one I actually enjoy too me too
I like the second one the first one
I really hated it because my
expectations were so big because it's a
book they make him likable in the book
and in these movies he's just not I
don't know I don't know if it's the
transition from the book to the movie or
just him as an actor I don't know what
it is I've seen this guy in interviews
and he's very charming he's not American
I don't know mrs. accent or something
he's very charming and I kind of get
what he's been going for I don't find
any of them sexy abusive yeah and I was
thinking about the last movie he's kind
of boring like he rarely talks he never
really laughs he's going to see I know
mrs. what's-her-face
Kim Basinger yeah he goes and sees her
doesn't even tell her like they
obviously don't have good communication
skills whatsoever
she tells she says to him like three
times a movie I love you and he doesn't
say it back so it's just like there's so
many things like I was kind of hoping
this movie was building to a point where
Christian gray evolved into like a real
obvious like hardcore abuser and she has
to leave him but I mean I thought the
first movie ends on a weird note like
that but I thought that this could have
been a cool study in lust versus love
they're with each other because of the
passionate sex but their relationship is
not imbued in real love but that's not
how this movie unfolds she had a good
scene that was a good scene a little
silly like in the car right and they
start having sex and then my hair cause
like we get yeah it was weird it's it
got to a point where I'm like one of the
sex scenes now feel forced it's not
exciting when they're married all the
steam and everything no I would rank it
two three one and they said the
flashback moments I thought they were
gonna show the ending flashback did you
remember how this movie ends or they do
have that trilogy flashback
[Music]
and also yeah that's true she's like
this supposedly like she wants to be
this independent woman but he didn't
basically get her job for her yeah I
think this is a sad tale I love how the
posters say don't miss the climax yeah
and they're building to like ultimate
kinky sex scene actually like Dakota
Johnson as an actress their chemistry in
the first movie was terrible and at
least the second one their chemistry
yeah that was the only thing about the
second one I like was like they actually
IV my girlfriend like my sister I just
can't even imagine his wife his wife
like could you imagine that I think that
that's why I Charlie Hunnam you know I
was originally supposed to do this I
think that his wife like put the nope on
it which I get it I mean they're you
know he's like licking her actual nipple
I mean I asked my girlfriend if if I
ever got cast in like a fifty Shades
movie would she be okay with that she
said she said she would break up with me
because I'm a guy who would sign on to
such a bad movie subscribe the reject
nation click that notification Belka
subscribe buttons don't really work
please check out a sh Leander on
Instagram I follow her like every other
photo you should also check her out on
YouTube yeah if I'm if I make a cameo
like a comment what a fun day that was
see you guys
[Music]